okay should we start right now hey
everybody uh thanks for coming uh my
name is Chen actually that's my last
name I go by my last name which is
easier for everybody so um I'm going to
very briefly describe uh the AB testing
functionality uh of the edex platform
and the U give a couple of examples of
the things that uh we're doing um or the
experiments that we're doing um using
this AB testing functionalities
um so you know as an introduction
teaching is a very old practice and then
um then came the great internet
Revolution and which enables us to teach
like
this um well so obviously we need to
find some better ways to teach online I
think that three slides is a pretty good
summary of a lot of the stuff that we
heard this
today uh so how can we what is the way
to find better ways to teach in an
online environment um muks has always
been you know give the same course
material to the entire moo population
and now we have what we really need is
this capability of giving uh traditional
uh teaching method to half of the class
and give experimental teaching method
things that we think might work in a
online environment to another group of
students and compare them um so this
function has just been realized by the
edex platform um which allows us to do
uh simple experimental designs like this
first we give some common course
material to the entire population and
then we uh randomly split the entire moo
population into two groups um so we give
half of them the treatment or the
experimental uh teaching uh method which
we think might work better uh we give
the other group the control and and then
we give them some common assessment very
simple um you can run multiple uh
experiments in a course with not much uh
interference uh because you can split
the course one way doing experiment one
and then you can split the course the
other way doing experiment two um and
these are independent random splits so
one split doesn't carry over to the
other split you you randomize them every
time and um if you if you experiment one
has multiple Parts you can also remember
your split so if you run experiment one
part one and experiment two in between
you can still remember what the the
first split is and you can use the same
split in another later unit uh which is
very uh useful to us because right now
there is no method for a student to say
that I opt out of any experiment so we
need to be fair to everybody what we did
was that uh we switched the uh treatment
and control groups for our experiments
so every time uh everybody has a fair
share of both experimental and uh
traditional um types of teaching um
so uh a little summary of some of the
features there's no limits on the number
of groups that we can have in uh you can
split the class
into uh a large number of different
groups hundreds of groups which is uh
possible given a moo given the scale of
a moo um each group can receive a
different number of materials which I
mean one group can receive five problems
and the other group can receive three
videos um there's you can do that um
group assignment is completely random so
um you can't say I have I I manually
match two populations because they have
the same uh abilities uh right now uh
the the assign I have no the course
creator has no control on the assignment
process we rely on Central limit Theory
um for fairness and no student can opt
out of any of the experiments a student
can't say I don't want to participate
just give me something that you used
last semester well sorry you have to we
we try to give you a flavor of
everything but you have to be part of
that okay so um some I'm going to give
you uh some
example of uh the experiments that we
run in this course first of all uh our
course is called 8m rev mechanics review
which is a college introductory level
mechanics uh calculus based mechanics
course uh it runs for 14 weeks uh 12
required units two optional units and as
you can see it started May 29th and it's
still not ended um which is why um today
I can't I don't have any um data to
present to you and I'll get to that
later um initially registered is 10 a
little bit above 10,000 um what is that
uh attempted about 4,000 people
attempted the second week's quiz
estimated so we ran a total of seven AB
experiments in our course A lot of them
are of interest to specifically to
physics Educators uh such as does a
diagram help students really help
students solve the problems and there
are some research that shows giv a
diagram actually Mak students less
likely to draw a diagram of their own
thus not helping them on problem solving
so we did something like giving a
problem with or without a diagram uh but
I'm try but today I'm going to um mainly
talk about uh a couple of them which I
think is more interesting to the broad
General uh more General audience uh the
first one says does length of a video
make a difference um there's research
that says people are more engaged in uh
shorter videos and we wanted to see if
that is true and how short does a video
have to be so what happened is that uh
we have these office hour videos where
Dave talks to uh students and um these
are called office hour videos and
they're 10 minutes in length um and they
talk about a challenging homework
problem and and um when we look at them
we think that they're a little bit too
long and students might not be focusing
on it all the time so what we did is
that we um cut the videos into short uh
two-minute segments of the videos each
covering sort of their own little topic
and we placed some questions in between
these videos and gave it to the students
um as a control we gave the whole
10-minute video at once and give the
students the exact EXA same questions
that were interleaved as a reminder of
the content of the
video so we set up the experiment like
this they were faced with this
challenging homework problem and they
are encouraged to attempt this once and
they are directed to this uh video help
session where half of them received the
long video version half of them received
the short video version um they were
then after watching the video they they
have the freedom to to choose how long
they want to watch these videos or how
many uh problems they questions they
want to attempt and they came back and
and and do that challenging homework
again so the research questions are well
are there any difference in time spent
watching the videos and um difference a
number of questions um so the um how
many questions do they answer before
they think that oh okay I got the
challenging problem and I wanted to go
back or um difference in Su successfully
solving the challenging homework problem
after watching the video is there a
difference in learning and by the way
these uh small questions counts like 0.1
points uh small enough that nobody would
really care
um and and so I would really like to
tell you that there uh the differences
that we're seeing but because of a
couple of issues that we really can't
pull out any uh trustworthy data out of
it
um
right yet exactly
yet we will be able to eventually um the
other big question that we want to um
ask is is it worth it or or is it worth
it to increase the interactivity of
course material because um students uh I
really don't want students to sit in
front of the computer screen like
watching a video or a movie just
passively receiving uh the information I
want them to be able to interact with
the course material that we give them
and the question is is that really
helping them to learn um and is it worth
it to spend that much effort into
increasing the interactivity so the
first thing we did is called traditional
problems versus direct measurement
problems which is the great contribution
by Peter boek here um so in a
traditional physics problem you get a
diagram and you get all the information
that you need to solve the problem uh
which is not showing up correctly here
uh so but but all the information is the
mass and the time is given and you solve
the problem from that uh what we are
able to what Peter boek um allows us to
do is that he provides this video player
that can play frame by frame which
allows you to measure Time by counting
the frames very precisely and then he
puts this ruler on top of the screen so
the distance is measured by the screen
ruler and then you can measure the prop
position of the angles and all the
things that you need
um so instead of giving you the
information we let the students measure
the information that they need uh to
calculate the problem the value of the
problem and we sort of give them um more
detailed instructions at first and then
we let them decide what they want to
measure later so the experimental setup
is pretty uh straightforward first we
introduced them to the concept then one
group was given the traditional homework
the other group was given the direct
measurement video uh and then we asked
some survey questions and some common
homework problems related to this
content to see if there's any
learning okay so research questions does
the extra interactivity result in more
participation or does the extra homework
leads to less
participation um anecdotally I saw two
posts two discussion posts related to
these V these videos one says I love
these contents the other
I love these videos the other says
that's why I became a
theorist
um can we identify any positive impact
in students knowledge to justify the
cost of creating these videos not just
um whether they are able to solve these
conventional problems better but can we
um so we ask them um do these videos
make you more sensitive to more aware of
uh experiment errors uh or the control
of errors and experiments or we even ask
them a question of if you CH slightly
change something in this experiment for
example you change the weight you change
the Str length of the string will it
increase or decrease your measurement
uncertainty things that um are of
obvious value to an experimental or any
physicist physics expert but are not
really um seen very often to in in a
traditional
problem now
the other um the other experiment that
we did is that we decid to to attack the
traditional multiple choice problems and
we developed something called the dragon
drop problem using the dragon drop
utility of the edex platform so in a
traditional multiple choice problem you
have the problem body and you have a
diagram and you have a couple of choices
what we don't like about it is we really
want the students to go back and forth
and think about what this math equation
means for this phys phics diagram
but uh a lot of the time is spent on
matching the choices to uh to the to the
diagram going between here and here
which is not essential to learning um
and it can become really bad if you for
example in this problem I ask you which
of the 12 positions choose uh all the
possible positions that uh uh is valid
under this math representation uh and so
we have have a a checkbox problem of 12
checkboxes which is really long um if
you're familiar with the uh education
literature you probably know this is a
lot of extraneous cognitive load by
which is a term coined by John sweller
uh which he claims to be not good for
Learning and so how do we
um so what we wanted to do is wanted to
make these problems a little bit more
straightforward so we designed things
like this now in this problem you're
your required to identify which of these
distances you should use for this R in
this equation and we created this R
locator which you could then drag to the
I I I'm going to use this as my R and
then I'm going to use this as my Alpha
which is which which saves you a lot of
the trouble going back and forth between
the choices and the content and here I
mean it is um you can drag I this this
point is valid for this this equation
and this point is also valid so you can
so so you can drag more directly um does
this change what effect does this change
have well also um this this utility
allows us to do something called
deliberate practice the work by ericon
which uh Susan singer mentioned this
morning that uh he studied what it takes
to become an expert it takes long and
repetitive practice in more detail it
requires Focus people to focus on
practicing one skill at a time for
example in football you you don't really
play the full game every time uh it
provide immediate providing immediate
specific feedback to the skill that
you're practicing on and then it
requires repetitive and highly focused
training on this one skill at a time so
if you want to focus on practicing one
skill at a time it relies on domain
specific problem design we as
instructors can design these problems
that focus on one practicing one skill
at a time uh autog grading customized
feedback this whole online education
platform sort of solves the immediate
specific feedback side of the issue and
what this interact increased
interactivity is designed to solve is
this to allow people to have repetitive
and highly focused training uh without
being uh overwhelmed by the uh
unnecessary effort of uh solving the
format of the
problem and so we divided the entire
population into three
groups um and one group receives a
traditional type of homework um the
other group receives a multiple choice
homework that focus on one skill but
incurs a lot of extraneous cognitive
load a third group received a
interactive Dragon drop problem a bunch
of interactive uh dragon drop problem in
that unit and we subject and after this
uh homework session we subjected them to
some common home homeworks and then a
common quiz and so these served as
assessments as to uh is there any
learning differences between these three
groups um so well because we have to be
fair to everybody we have to rotate uh
between all three groups which means we
created nine units worth of homework
which is a lot of work um which is one
thing that we didn't realize initially
when we were designing the experiment in
the
moo so research questions are does
increasing interactivity result in more
engagement are student more deliberate
in terms of the practice are they you
know does this new format make them
practice more with the homework and then
compared to traditional problems do drag
and drop problems serves as Better or
Worse assessments uh because a lot of
times you have bad problems just because
the problem itself is too complicated
not because the content is too hard and
do these solve uh these kind of problems
the third question is do deliberate
practice results in any detectable
learning gain which is what we wanted to
um we wanted to find out so this is all
I have to talk to you and um before I I
have a couple of uh questions that I
would like to discuss among us but
before that I would like to ask if you
have any comments or any
questions um yes uhk thank you could you
could you please yeah uh could you
please talk into the microphone yeah
thank
you and could you please introduce
yourself before uh Zach paros University
of California Berkeley okay um I have a
question about uh the logistics of
running experiment okay uh when it comes
to the discuss discussion forum or other
areas where there might be socialization
going on yes does it split the forums as
well um yeah no it doesn't so what
happens is that we have
um each group has its own uh discussion
forum entrance point so uh we have a
discussion forum entrance point right
beneath the problem but uh and you can
only see in that entrance point you will
see all the discussion pertaining to
that problem but if you go to the
general discussion forum you can see um
other people's discussion about this uh
about all the other contents and we have
to tell them beforehand although we
don't really want to that uh from from
this week on you will be seeing some
some people's posts will not make sense
to you sort of like that because we're
we're testing uh different content and
you'll have a chance to experience what
they've experienced this
week um follow and and uh I didn't uh
another comment is that I don't really
see people uh being very angry saying
why do these guys receive much better
much more interesting things than than I
do that that was one of the initial
worries and that didn't really happen uh
if I could be allowed to ask one more
question um uh what kind guidance can
you give with regard to requesting
informed consent or how did you proceed
along those lines and what did your IRB
uh have to say about that okay so um so
what we did was that uh we have this
little paragraph in our when they
register for the course we have this
little paragraph saying um we are doing
research in this course and if you
register clicking register uh means that
you agree to participate in this uh we
will be trying um these uh Innovative
instructional methods and clicking
register means that you agree to
participate in this yeah that's all we
did um how do you handle students under
18 because you need parental consent to
do
this um uh good question um I don't I
don't really I don't really know the
answer to it because we we tried running
this and this was actually a very tricky
thing but okay substantial number of the
students in our class were under 18 and
so you either have to you have to either
exclude them or you have to get parental
consent okay otherwise you're not
following I don't know if it's federal
law or federal guidelines but you can
get in trouble for not doing that
because they give us we we try to by the
IRB and this was a big issue where they
were like very worried about it okay um
Dave do you know how we get by the issue
of uh people under
18 that that is a very small minority
and uh oh
sorry so yeah we have IRB approval and
actually the 18 uh
wasn't uh that that that was not the
thing they were most concerned about uh
the the things that that they were
concerned about and that we we uh were
fortunate to get a good ruling on was
the question of informed consent okay
well you have to be informed about the
experiment before you click the register
buttons okay fine that's good but then
the ability to withdraw from the study
at any time and uh and we got them to
wave that on the basis that anybody can
just leave the boot they're not required
in any way to participate and so uh so
so that was the
decision hi I think and also we we we
uh we keep all of our identified data on
a secure server not hooked up to the
Internet and and then we can de identify
that according to MIT rules and use use
that but I think that that's obviously
got to be part of it because you have to
be very careful under the fer rules with
with data for
miners I'm Rohit Nal I I'm at the
poverty action lab here at MIT so just a
question on your outcome measures so one
early on you said participation was one
measure was that just based on
participation in the discussion forum or
uh what do you use to measure
participation no actually uh if you
count the participation on the
discussion forum you will get numbers
such as five or three which doesn't
really make much sense U so
participation is for example in the
video experiments we were trying to see
you know how much of the video do
students uh watch before they start to
get bored or before they skip to other
units and um and also students you know
only need to get 60% of the the points
although we have very serious people we
also have people who selectively uh get
60% of the scores and then said I'm done
with it and do these people uh choose to
do these more interactive problems s or
do they you know once they've seen these
interactive problems do they still are
they still willing to do these more uh
traditional type of problems that's our
question yeah I just had a follow up on
the IRB kind of question because um you
know I I have a bit of a developmental
psych background too and um we've kind
of run into this um and and it really
regardless of how many like you know
under 18 people you have like it really
is an issue okay um and there a couple
different ways I think that you can
approach it um so one thing that's going
on in the developmental psychology world
right now is a big discussion about we
really need to make it easier you know
to get IRB approval for um experiments
that are kind of on this level that are
really like really not harmful that are
really educational pedagogy you know
that are things that maybe teachers will
be doing anyway so that's pretty easy to
get that kind of well I mean you know
depending on your institution and
whatever you have to go through um but
typically I think you know it's not it's
pretty straightforward to to try to
apply for um you know a waiver of the
whole informed consent if you're doing
just manipulation of pretty
straightforward educational pedagogy
that's not going to damage anybody it's
just going to see if a different
strategy helps that kind of thing and I
know that several organizations are
working on trying to apply that more
easily to kids um you know you can get
waivers of consent to test at a school
and they just haven't worked it out you
know for the online environment but I
think that of course in light of right
Facebook and and all that stuff we all
want to be really careful and and cover
all our bases and and all that stuff but
I think that the waivers in in light of
you know that that this is a change in
educational pedagogy we don't need to
scare people you know from participating
and we do need this data and it is
really like potentially very beneficial
and not harmful you know manipulation of
the structure of it so as as long as you
start to like frame it that way we've
always been able to like do it that
way okay yes uh whoever was the mic I am
uh Dan leevy from the Harvard Kennedy
School involving Harvard X
research I guess my question may be um
related to something you haven't done
yet cuz you haven't faced the data um
but I I wanted to ask you a little bit
about the the structure of the data you
will be getting is such that
um you know in a traditional classroom
you have the students all right they do
this and then they do this and then they
do that in a Muk uh you have no control
over what they do or whether they do
anything um and so wondering how you
dealt in the design of the experiments
with the uh potential drop off at
different points of the experiment the
fact that some students might completely
skip your treatment and go into the quiz
directly and then go back to the
treatment and so just that
Dynamic um dimension of the muks in
which the Learners are just doing
whatever they want rather than
uh what you have in mind for them and
how you dealt with that in the in the
design and if you have any thoughts on
how you'll deal with that in the
analysis of the data that would be great
uh thank you great question uh basically
uh we didn't do much design on that we
design our we try to design our
experiments to be local experiments that
doesn't expand through two units um
because students might not do the other
units and and uh we have this sequence
of you know instructional content
homework and quiz and um we are assuming
that students follow the general path of
looking at the content doing the
homework and doing the quiz or at least
do the homework first before they do the
quiz because quiz are higher Stakes so
it makes sense to at least practice on
the homework and then do the quiz um
actually I was I have a discussion uh I
have a discussion question myself that
that asks how do we design these because
my background and I believe a lot of
people's background are from designing
experiments for a traditional classroom
where you have a lot of control over
students come in they do this I collect
this and give them give it to them how
do we adjust to the Muk population and
how do we adjust the design to the moo
population yes and so we're we're open
to any suggestions thank
you yes so Amy Bennett from the
University of Pennsylvania uhuh I'm
interested in let's say the data come
back okay
and interactive design is better small
videos are better shorter videos are
better
where at what point do you reconcile the
investment required versus the outcome
you expect and do you plan to put that
into your traditional classroom which
might make that investment a little bit
easier to bear so how do you deal with
that okay uh thank you um first of all I
would feel really lucky if it comes back
and uh one group actually learns more
than the other group because you know uh
I would be happy if I see some
difference in behavior in the two groups
because uh moo is such a special uh
population that eventually you're left
with certificate earners who are really
serious about it and you can give them
anything and they will do it um and in
terms of justifying the
cost well
um we actually didn't have a very good
idea of how much effort it would take to
create them before we created them we
are learning by doing because these and
and uh you know the more we create them
the easier it becomes for example these
Dragon drop problems initially creating
one drag and drop problem will take me
half a day because there are so many
parameters that you have to measure the
pixels on the graphs it's ridiculous and
then as as as as we created more and
more of them uh people started to join I
asked people can you create create a
tool for us now we have this tool to
create really fancy drag and draw
problems in a matter of you know 10 20
minutes if you have the design um so and
in terms of the actually I have another
discussion question let me just show you
all the discussion questions that I have
the other discussion question is um what
criteria how should
we what criteria should we use to judge
whether one pedagogy is better than
another learning engagement more
discussion
ah how do I do
that
hold yeah um sorry about that let me see
if I can anyway um okay let me let me do
this later so so we're the the answer is
that um also we're not sure um what does
it mean to be uh to say one uh
instructional method is better than the
other instructional method open to open
to
suggestions
um yes that is that
um I forgot is there another question
that you had yeah I mean it's just
thinking about the outcome of your
experiment so it's one thing to collect
data and analyze then what do you do
about it so are you prepared to do
something about it whether the resources
take that or not and if if so how and if
not well
uh uh uh um apparently uh when we get
the data and get the results it's going
to inform us what we did was good and
what we did was not worth it and then I
hope it will tell us you know uh what
what we have done what we could have
done and what we should have done in the
future and in the next run we may so for
example if we find one way of doing
things is definitely better than the
other then we don't do it as an AB test
and we just implement it from then on
and recommend it to the community saying
uh you should really cut the videos into
two-minute segments it's very easy to do
and and just do it um in other cases we
may find that oh we screwed up here
and we can keep it as an AB test and and
find out you know if there's a better
way that leads to better results thank
you so some of the ab tests you showed
were kind of content specific in terms
of they were directed toward
understanding if one particular
pedagogical practice was good for your
particular class something that would be
interesting to run in an AB format it
would be to look at practices kind of
span lots of different mukes um a couple
of examples of things that' be I'd like
to know actually if you could figure
them out would be for example the hard
deadlines versus soft deadlines one of
the questions this inspires great debate
whenever we run our Muk is you know well
these deadlines are really tough and
they're mean and you know if you had
softer deadlines everything would be
Rosy and we've run another moo where
we've had soft deadlines and the other
the way around well hard deadlines we
like hard deadlines because it makes us
get it done and now we kind of
procrastinate a second question would be
interesting is the notion of running
cohorts versus running it more
self-paced yeah um you know you could
essentially the way we run it one is
essentially it's one week on one topic
you switch to the next week everything's
done everything stays in the sync Y and
on the other hand you could imagine kind
of some range where maybe you overlap
weeks of content or you just let it be
entirely self-paced so if you had a kind
of robust enough AB infrastructure I
think those would be really interesting
questions to answer not just for your
particular class but in general the
pedagogy of Muk yeah exactly U sure
other
comments comment about that uh we we are
uh really about last week last summer
course after we ran our we're we're on
our fourth move now and uh and at first
we were just barely keeping ahead of the
Title Wave uh in terms of getting the
content out there but but subsequently
we've had the policy especially since
we've given these courses in the summer
that somebody be able to have have the
material available four weeks in
advance uh so that someone can go on a
one Monon vacation and and and not lose
any credit uh but but we do have
deadlines for when the material you know
when the tests are due when the material
is due and what we find is that most of
the students are pretty much in the
current week I mean the discussions are
current they can get some response to
discussion for I don't know what it is
but mostly the students stay stay up the
majority of the students are are
basically yeah so let me respond because
you you you you've tried it one way but
I think one one observation about a 14we
class for example is we've run I think I
think six or seven sessions now and it's
a hard hard and fast rule every week the
class goes on when we run it we lose 10%
of our students because just life
intervenes and people disappear in terms
of you know things come up my girlfriend
broke up with me and so i' I'd be
curious to know like running your course
is a is a kind of a 14-week thing if you
thought about for example try and
compressing it down to a seven-week
Thing versus running it as a 28 28 we
thing run versus running at asynchronous
because I suspect that there's some
Dynamics in there in terms of how it
fits the students you're doing that
would be very interesting to kind of
pull out and if you could do AB testing
you could do that um yeah although uh we
my view is I'm not responsible for the
people who registered and then
participated only peripherally or not at
all but in our courses the people who've
made an attempt at the second assignment
like a quarter of that uh we find that
half to two to to three4 of them will
actually get certificates so we do not
seem to be experiencing as rapid uh drop
offs as is in the other introductory
physics moves and I don't know the
reason so that's not really high on our
agenda right now although I think we do
see and I know in other cases there's a
very strong correlation of the dropout
rate being people who have less
educational background and less
skill and also a comment uh I just
thought about uh I I just realized that
the current AB testing structure
does not allow you to fiddle with the
deadlines so so you can give them
different contents but not different
deadlines you it for that you have to
have a new course yes thanks I keep
forgetting to introduce myself before I
right I I guess everybody forgot most of
the people forgot but my name is
Katherine and um I'm from
UCSD um yeah so I had a question um just
sort of a general question for everybody
too but related to this I think that
it's important to distinguish between
right learner preferences and things
that help people learn and sometimes
they're the same thing and sometimes
they're really not and I don't know how
it all works out in muks especially
because I think that you know oftentimes
it's really important to cater to
learner preferences because otherwise
people drop out more easily right well
Susan this morning just said the
opposite yeah I mean it it depends on
how you slice and dice right those kinds
of experiments but I think that that is
something that I I really you know want
to start app
this experimental testing to is like are
there things that Learners really prefer
like they really like you know Snappy
YouTube videos but they don't learn
anything from them you know or find
those golden things that they love and
are good actually a comment on this uh
when we
introduced these drag and drop problems
we first introduced it to our 80 beta
testers and 10 20 of them are really
serious and I got bipolar uh responses I
mean of course anybody who uh bothers to
respond is going to be sort of on one
and on the other but there are people
said this is the greatest thing that
I've ever seen in muks and there are
people who absolutely hated it because
that they can't get it to so I think um
when I was designing these experiments
my mindset was still in the classroom I
was still my student simulator in my
brain was still simulating the undergrad
students that I interacted with in the
classroom not this broad spectrum and
then the other problem is that we really
didn't thought about it was that some
people are taking these mukes on iPads
and these Dragon drop problems despite
the fact that they look like they should
be dragable with your finger actually do
not it people hated it so we really have
a wide spectrum of of of population that
we need to deal with and requires a lot
of data mining in the end to to tease
out you know if there's one population
that loves Dragon Rob and there's
another who really hates it and what's
the difference thank
you okay so I I finally uh pulled up all
the discussion questions that I I wrote
up the other day that I wish to stir
some discussions so we've sort of
covered other Innovative instructional
methods worth putting online and testing
via AB
experiments um welc come any suggestions
and then how should we design our
experiments to suit this unique moo
population as I just mentioned you know
these people behave rather differently
from our uh in-class students um and if
we want to study uh for example are are
people engaging more or not engaging
more should we be looking into the
certificate earn ERS or not uh or or the
people who drop at the middle of the way
um things like
that
um one thing that I think we haven't
touched so far is this how do we
design effective assessment of learning
when students have the freedom to access
essentially any external resource they
have we are not in a closed book example
era anymore it's all open book exam um
any ideas
anybody resources and learn I mean
should you know to I think I think he
made this point earlier that in some
sense if they're using external
resources and are actually working in
the spirit of learning then it's fine
for them to use external resources
because that's the reality of the world
we work in um true but then uh how do
you know that the difference that you're
seeing is CA caused by uh your
um the thing that you did in the ab
experiments not that group b suddenly
discovered a better uh resource out
there or Group B has more population in
the United States where they can access
this YouTube video where group a has
more Indian population where they are or
Chinese population with they're block
from this I think that's just a
limitation of working in an open roll
online class that you may not be able to
have such precisely control exper but
you might be able to compensate with
massive numbers that might give you some
statistical confidence
okay okay Dan hi Chen uh Daniel seeden
from MIT um a lot of the discussion I'm
shooting from the hip here so bear with
me um but it seems like uh in regard to
your question how should we design our
experiment
um potentially putting these sort of ab
tests into a a very independent module
from the course could be quite
interesting um between 801x 82x and ADM
rev you probably have 14 to say 15,000
people who've got a certificate um and
emailing those people and asking them to
to participate in beta testing one of
these modules could get you a lot of
people you could very easily give an
entrance survey to find out who they are
um and then begin sort of splicing on on
how they interact with these different
modules in a very setting it even could
possibly um get around the issue of
18year olds because you can simply say
if you're not 18 please don't take this
but it but it's not to say you shouldn't
do things in course but you could very
quickly design something that you could
put out there for for people to do the
one concern I have uh regarding to your
suggestion is that uh are these beta
testers can you treat these beta testers
equivalent as your normal students right
because they are certificate earners
they are themselves a special population
right sure and that's this is and this
is an experiment right and that brings
me to the other question that I have on
the list which just gone blue is that to
what extent can we safely say that uh
the results we obtained through a moo
experiments can be transferred to a flip
classroom despite the great difference
in
population uho yeah uho Joe tennis from
uh edex so uh also thinking about the
question of Assessments uh when you have
open
materials um if we think of learning
research and really getting to the nuts
and bolts of what exact things help
people then there's clearly benefits of
having very contained experiments that
test just one thing and U but I think
that if we think from the other side of
the spectrum that we want to educate
people to be contributing citizens and
uh good professionals then like was
commented that's the world of open
resources so with the large statistics
and knowing that that's how lots of
things work I think AB testing could
still give us guidance maybe would be
challenging to find out exactly the
Dynamics but uh but yeah I'd love to see
lots of assessment moving to a situation
that cannot be gained with open uh
resources because that's the real world
problems that the students will be
facing yeah yeah that's right thanks
what I'm what I'm just saying is that uh
uh the things that we are putting online
right now sort of evolved from a closed
book format traditional closed book
format and how to evolve them into
suiting this on open book format is a
challenge that we need to face thank you
um anybody
else okay so I actually do everything on
Cor so I I've just poked around edex a
little bit okay I'm from rice I'm Joe
Warren okay so is
the Avail
Studio I created um this is a very early
adoption of the ab test it just wrote
out and we just adopted it
and the same thing can be said about
anything that is just wrote out it
involves a lot of work and it involves
XML and doing things by hand uh to this
day I haven't I haven't uh seen an
official release that it is available in
studio but I have seen draft
documentation that it will be yeah Tempo
I can just comment very briefly so last
I heard which is about a month ago 95%
of it was in studio so you had to set up
your cohort setup in XML and imported in
and then everything else you could do in
studio
and yeah but we are really pushing hard
to get it fully there it may already be
there or maybe in next few weeks next
few
months yeah uh so so when I edited it uh
I need to set up the AB testing in XML
and once I set it up and imple uh
imported it I can view the content and
edit the content you just need to have
the a group infrastructure in there and
in the draft document that I
documentation that I saw uh they have a
model of the inter how what the
interface would look like to you know
for for you to click a button and say I
have group a and Group B and Group C
that's that's in the near future that's
all I can say
yeah um you don't want to work with XML
nowadays when student courses are in
studio
right
um okay
um anything
else my name is sa Fran I worked with d
Richard U on making MRA before it became
mrav and um I mean most of the time I
spend my time sort of making new mukes
so I never have time to actually test
them but uh I think there are two
differences I can see here because I
have I I I have exposure and have some
background in education research but um
I think of myself mostly As teaching
physics and trying to figure out what is
it that I want to do in my class and uh
I think AB testing could be a tool for
research but could also be a tool for
teachers to figure out what is it that
they want to do and and um uh I I I
think that that that sometimes might be
even more powerful because I I really
doubt that you can get enough control to
do do ab studies to figure out how
attrition will vary when you do the
course uh it it takes a huge time to
really build one of these courses and
run them and and um I I have even doubts
that you can really split the course
into three groups is it's like you're
running three different sections at the
same time um I think people have done
studies like this for example they done
studies how fors behave
and bu forms that are musicing sharing
sites you know they split in the 67
cohor that are kind of transar all the
users and they study the behavior how
the forums work so I think it's really a
good question of the platform builders
that they can put the functionality in
there you can answer a lot of questions
I'm not saying it's easy of course there
is not I don't know where they at on AB
testing I've heard rumors that they know
they have some Secret bill that has AB
testing on but I've never seen any hid
hair of it but I think it's interesting
if you could do that because again we
talked a little bit attrition rates and
I mean I don't I don't I kind of have my
theory about how it works but you know
you have a different theory in the way
to settle is we could have
infrastructure that we could build
classes on I think we can really answer
these questions and and to each other I
think that these experiments have to be
run and rerun in different context with
different populations because I mean we
teach physics and what we see in physics
probably very different from what you
see that's why I like testing because
inance you can just isolate this single
variable I realize class L like tricky
to do but like hard deadline verus
deadline that's something that sounds
like it's not impossible to do in a
current infrastructure and you could you
know B one one court that gets a you
know a different deadline or a different
set of deadlines on there that to me
would be again an interesting question
would apply to lot of
cles but I I would really like to see
people use this stuff and and um one of
the things I think about is that movs
are not are a lot of things so you do a
Muk and I like the idea of sort of
finding the M over and over again where
you get to a point where you take your
content you trying to figure out as a
teacher what is it that works for you
best and and more of the community do
these things and share them uh I think
like C consumer research more than just
just education research because the the
the the overhead in running education
research you have to have a group like
big Pritchard or or someone else to
really do these studies but as a teacher
we can share experiences by you know I'm
doing this with my students and I think
this works I I I I just feel that the
the the the infrastructure is there is
done by adex but maybe there should be
some guidelines for I think there's one
piece that is missing for for it to be
able to do what you do is the that right
now if I click on the instructor
dashboard and see wanted to see um how
many students in group a did it and how
many students in group b did it uh I was
explicitly told that the numbers are not
trustworthy um so so there's some issue
with AB testing structure and the
instructor dashboard export that doesn't
allow me to do it so uh I think if we
can um in sort of in real time when the
course is running see the effects of AB
testing then that will be a very
valuable thing otherwise you have to
have a data Miner to tell you what uh
what it does
yeah uh yeah
Dave so um when I started u teching my
educ oh yeah when I when I made the
decision to push my education research
group away from mastering physics uh and
and into the broader edex thing one of
the big reservations that I had and
continue to have about mooes is what a
dumb idea in the following sense
uh we know that the internet is really
suited to
individualized television programming
for instance and in fact it has had a
very delerious effect on network
television because now you can watch
just the the the particular news program
with the Viewpoint that you like or
whatever it is why is this idea of
inventing Network education the wave of
the
future and I want to just ask here say
as we now get three four five 10
introductory physics courses should we
all be trying to to take and educate all
comers like the Muk philosophy or
mightn't it be a lot better to say have
one concentrate on professional people
another concentrate for teachers another
concentrate for people trying to take
advanced placement tests which is
actually what we're trying to do this
spring uh I mean what what's the feeling
that that you should how many people
think I really love the idea of mukes
and I want to keep them open to all
comers and how many people think oh it
might be really better to specialize
because because we could get better
research and find treatments that are
suited for just that cohort so how many
people are the generalists how many
people here want come on tppo you're in
you're in
edex that's why I am
neutral okay one two three four I guess
and how many people think it might be a
good idea to specialize more to a
particular
cohort one two three if you
think you can vote twice if you want
yeah
one two three so that's about seven
eight
depends or
like it's a little bit all about the
money right I mean you know it's kind of
like well what are what are Department
you know Department of Education
interested in funding or are we trying
to do something remedial are we trying
to do something like that you can't get
in in schools I think they're all these
people trying to do all these things so
I don't know it's if there are all these
different ways to approach it so you're
really a specialist all H shouldn't do
all these things no I don't think they
can you know that's I I think that in
this country right we have such an issue
with standardization like in the
education system and kind of pushing for
it like the the you know Universal
mediocrity or something like
that but at the same time like it's a
valid concern that you want everybody to
like have access to the same thing that
equal playing field which we also very
much value so if you know if decide it's
really important to those kids who like
don't have pre-algebra and you need to
level them up or something then you're
going to be more focused on you know
universally accessible you know maybe
remedial is kind of a negative word but
you know just that kind of foundational
thing or maybe you're really more
interested in like what do schools not
provide at all I don't know which we
have a big bigger need for but yeah it
seems like people are more more willing
to fund like you know things that
immediately will pay off in in terms of
Workforce of
course um I think it's partly just a
function of uh who we are uh we meaning
those of us who produce muks uh we are
primarily College faculty members who
teach these General courses uh and it's
not that we are trying to not do
specialized courses as you know
something like 70% of moo Learners are
college educated and I think that's
basically F know when we produce things
here at MIT we tend to produce things
that are uh of MIT uh quality and so I'm
producing a mook right now uh and
yesterday we had one of the final
meetings and I looked at it and said Gee
this is way too
hard it's not what I intended I wanted
this to be much know broader in fact and
available for high school students but
it's sort of natural that we we come to
to this kind of content and assessment
and it's it's you know we have to change
who we are if we're going to go where
where you want to
go uh and and this brings me to
something that I really wanted to have
in the uh moo any moo platform which is
badges which means that you can say um I
have this module that says angular
momentum level one and you master that
and you said I'm angular momentum level
one you're allowed to go to angular
momentum level two at any time you
choose or you're allowed to go to
conservation of angular momentum level
one uh so that right now as a moo
Creator I think these huge uh courses
are too big of a beast for anybody to uh
tackle because you know uh to run this
one course sucked up all of our energies
and we really um stretched ourselves
pretty thin to design these experiments
and and make one good unit so uh I'm a
big advocate of having smaller more uh
more unit like uh mukes so that each Moo
can be welld designed and um and and
then you're more custom you can have
your own custom learning paths taking
one badge after another after another
and then for you you can have you know
level one level two level three level
impossible that's that's what I want
yeah okay uh I think time is up I'm
happy to talk to anybody um after this
and so thank you all for
attending